want to read a quote to you chris here
and it has to do with John Paxson John
Paxson is the Bulls president of
basketball operations now he said this
yesterday in a quote the important thing
for us is if we're ever going to be in a
position we're going to rebuild there
has to be certainty and what you're
getting back if you're going to go that
route you better have certainty you can
get several young assets that are
legitimate those kind of things don't
exist now because we thought Jimmy
Butler is going to be traded to the
Celtics he then goes on to say this
right now today Jimmy is on our roster
under contract for two more years Paxson
said you guys know this league is fluid
what's John Paxson saying there I mean
isn't that the mother of all quotes I
mean the right now imagine saying that
to your girlfriend like right now you're
my girlfriend today I mean it's you know
it's not exactly the longest endorsement
of Jimmy Butler's future you know
Chicago you alluded to it you know they
want to see what that draft pick turns
into if it's the number one overall pick
they are absolutely going to get back
engaged with Boston and Boston will
re-engage with them but the Celtics at
the same time you know one thing that I
was closed aware of yesterday and
talkative teams that had at least taken
the temperature of Boston is that they
were valuing the 2017 Brooklyn pick as
number one they were saying expect this
to be March helpfuls expect this to be a
transcendent point guards that can shape
your franchise and other teams weren't
exactly doing that now if that turns out
to be Markel folks the stuff is going to
turn around say the Chicago you know
look this is now officially this player
a lot of the other stuff is off the
table you're not going to be able to
extract Jae Crowder you're not going to
be able to extract jaylen Brown will
still put this pick up because you know
frankly they don't have a lot of use for
it and Butler is a better player for
them but that would put Boston in a much
better bargaining position at the same
time if it winds up number four which we
have seen in the past not in the self
examines that great luck it puts the
Celtics at a top of position as well so
there were
a lot of calculated risks taken
yesterday on Boston's behalf on
Indiana's behalf and on strike Chicago's
behalf and I I know that the lakers are
interested in Paul George and Paul
George sounds like he's interested in
the Lakers and I agree with the Lakers
if you're going to if you know you can
get him there's no need to get him now
if you know that you can get him in the
offseason do you think that that's
what's going to happen with these two
teams well two things the Lakers were
never close on anything because nobody
is is going to make a deal with the
Lakers until they know if they're
keeping their draft pick and that tick
as you know if it's outside the top
three it conveys to Philadelphia so
there's no deal with la until after the
lottery is complete and look it's
dangerous for a team in a major market
like LA to just think that a Paul George
is going to want to go there I mean
they're the NB has changed so much and
yeah I believe that that George is
interested in playing in LA but you know
if over the next year and a half you
know they've made no significant
improvements and Magic Johnson's like
the same type of GM that Phil Jackson
and guad a diva had become you know he's
not going to run there I mean he'll open
up his his list of possibilities to a
number of different teams so you know I
think the lakers they had never had a
chance but if we have a chance this
summer and if they can move an Ingram
and a draft pick to go get him it would
behoove Magic Johnson lag you know
talking to gm's has been very aggressive
in this last week it would Google who've
Magic Johnson to try to do that if I
look at the young talent that the Lakers
have Jim Buss lost his job Mitch Kupchak
lost his job but if people value the
young talent the Lakers have and they
don't want to get rid of them didn't bus
and Kupchak do a good job then they have
done a very good job this year they did
not do a great job in the offseason when
they went out and paid luol deng far
more money than anyone was going to give
them when they overpaid for Timofey
Mozgov and in talking to some executives
bait they tell me that those contracts
they're really going to come back to
bite the lakers in the long term I mean
they're going to be cap killers for this
team
the next couple of years they try to
reshape their roster in creatin see but
Ingram you know an obvious choice at
number two he looks like a player and
Randall and Russell are pretty good so
you know there there there and there
okay there the irony in some ways band
is that you know they hire Rob link as
the general manager and Rob palanca was
the guy that note negotiated that cap
destroying contract that Kobe Bryant
died a couple of years ago I mean can we
just pause for a second and note the
irony in that particular move so the
deal that the decision to fire you know
Jim and Mitch had little to do with what
was happening today as much did you know
the last couple of years I got the
feeling that the rest of the league says
it's going to be a rematch again between
the cabs in Golden State and let's if
we're going to regroup let's let's try
to do something for 2017 or 2018 your
thoughts on the rest of the league kind
of put their arms up saying all right we
surrender well you know the Western
Conference certainly is doing that you
know the Clippers you know they might
have had an opportunity to make compact
deal they'll willing to dig even deeper
into their draft reservoir which is
already pretty tapped at this point but
they didn't want to go there I mean
Houston made some some nice moves and
they're starting to position themselves
as a team that can score with Golden
State and San Antonio they're going to
get into the Andrew Bogut sweepstakes if
if and when Bogut is bought out in these
next couple of days so but but you're
right in the Western Conference sense
and he's so I mean even though boss
didn't make a deal Toronto is you know
their threat right now dad I mean Ibaka
is is a big upgrade for them and PJ
Tucker comes in he all of a sudden can
replace what they lost in turns Ross so
you know I think the Raptors who took
the cab 6 games last year if a Bach is
motivated and if ibaka is the player we
saw during his prime in Oklahoma City
which he could still be I mean he you
know he's 27 years old he's just hitting
the prime years of his career if he's
motivated to play like that this is a
team to watch it righto no question
Chris safe travels always great to talk
to you thank you you got a damn Chris
Mannix from the vertical on yahoo he and
loads did a great job yesterday keeping
us up-to-date on the potential
rage but i would keep an eye on Jimmy
Butler is still ending up with the
Celtics because of those cryptic
messages that John Paxson had yesterday
reading between the lines feels like
they had a deal in place but the Bulls
aren't sure who they're getting in
return and probably said hey neither of
us you know I week we can both wait here
we can both wait in the offseason and
feels like that's what's going to happen
the Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience
[Music]